[Musique]
oui bonjour mathieu
dit moi je t'appelle parce que je suis
en rupture de stock de thon livre le
jour où les antilles feront peuple et je
voulais savoir si c'était possible de me
faire une petite commande sept parcours
plutôt atypique pour cette jeune femme
de 35 ans ancienne étudiante en bts
gestion elle a aussi tenté de devenir
préparatrice en pharmacie mais l'insee
et surtout une passionnée des livres l
homme a écrit eux sorti en avril 2021 et
quelques mois après en décembre elle
ouvre son enseigne la motivation le
manque de diversité je trouvais que
malheureusement
on a beaucoup d'auteurs antillais mais
malheureusement livre noir d'auteur noir
et de personnages noirs sont
malheureusement pas assez diffusé donc
je tenais à coeur d'avoir un lieu
spécialement dédiée pour eux alors pour
les enfants n'a réussi sa lumière
magique garçon qu'il vit une histoire
avec la manie une nouvelle librairie
alors que le secteur connaît une
véritable saignée la librairie
antillaise a changé de nom les
librairies gros des ormeaux et alexandre
qui ont fermé et on annonce la
disparition de présence crayonne au mois
de septembre alors forcément ce nouveau
venu à tous pinière diamant surprend son
monde il ya plus à auteuil à feu
prêt-à-porter tout une petite librairie
ici c'est très bien c'est très bien
c'est intime sur tout et on peut
discuter avec la propriétaire à peine à
six mois d'existence et déjà plus de 500
références en boutique beaucoup de
livres pour les très jeunes c'est de
tout petits sont déjà des habitués
ils appellent même la gérante tati plus
belle la
vie vers cela que j'aime d'un livre
c'est comment se fait la manière dont
ces écrits les images les couleurs et
comment ces écrits et puis aidé ça que
j'aime bien lindsay veut s'emparer de la
littérature afro caribéenne elle estime
même qu'il lui appartient d'en faire la
promotion c'est un challenge il faut que
les livres est il faut que les livres
perdure il faut que nos enfants puissent
avoir des livres avec des personnages
qui leur ressemble et ça c'est que le
rôle de libraires et c'est important que
ça à ça perdure 6 heures le temps pour
vivre la librairie ne se comptera pas
que de vendre des livres des ateliers et
des animations régulièrement font partie
du business plan pour se maintenir à
flot